[Music]  Ramzi in my opinion one of the greatest  evil characters in the history of  [Applause]  something I think playing an amazing  villain is one of the hardest things in  the world to walk that line I despised  you and loved and thought you were just  amazing at the same time have you met  people though who really liked your  character yeah what does that mean what  does that say about them they're really  they're really favorite character walk  away there's one over there yeah you  receipt it's lovely when people actually  like someone that's so horrible yeah how  did you learn because I'm talking about  when when an actor learns that his  character is through on Game of Thrones  how did you learn that it was over for  you in the traditional sense of a phone  call from these two gentlemen where they  called me and they said so  congratulations  Ramsay gets to the Iron Throne isn't  that amazing at which point I knew I was  dead yeah  you